through the morning smog the towers of
ribnik's power station
run on coal like most of the country
there is a smell
in the air here like an open fire
the air is choked polluted with
particles that can cause serious health
problems
and which kill nearly fifty thousand
people a year
in poland joanna has lived in ribnik for
forty years
she now has problems with her lungs
heart spine
even her brain
i don't have that many years left ahead
of me now so climate change might not
affect me
but i have children and grandchildren
and i'd like for them to live in a good
world
but i don't have much hope families here
worry and with good reason
a recent study found that children in
rhythmic have five
times more black carbon particles in
their body than kids from france
we found them in urine the belgian
scientist behind the project
were shocked by what his report revealed
so the black carbon
levels found in the children's urine is
are high we have never seen such a high
exposure there are very limited studies
i must say
to measure exposure inside
the body but this is clearly reflecting
what is going outside in the air they
are carcinogenic
we know that these particles also are
causing cardiovascular disease
and at these levels they are
really at the levels that we can expect
clear health
consequences of it emil's ten-year-old
son anthony took part in that study
the pollution in the air around him will
have
long-term impacts on his health his
family
are scared about letting him out of
their flight
and here's why emil has paid for an air
filtration system in this home
look at the state of the filters after
just three months use
oh that's horrible
black with toxic pollutants
some dna vroco there are days of the
year when we feel like prisoners in our
own homes
we check the air quality on our
smartphones and we know that we can't go
out for our own health
this is not a normal situation it can't
be like this anymore
[Music]
he's angry poland isn't doing more to
stop its addiction to coal
used in domestic heating as well as
power stations
i'm certainly terrified knowing what i
what my family and what my child
breathes in
is really uncomfortable it worsens the
perception of how
life is here the eu wants to hasten the
end too as part of a long-term plan for
a greener future
but the polish government is wary the
life is much more important than job
but how would you live without job it's
all about money
it is true it's all about money because
the money
will provide the stable jobs
this is bell hatoff a sprawling
combination of
open cast coal mining and a massive
power station
every second this power plant burns
through a ton
of dirty lignite coal it is
the biggest polluter in europe
so you can see a line between this and
the health problems
that we've heard about in this country
but this power station
also generates 20 of poland's
electricity you can't just
turn it off what this country needs is a
clear path towards
cleaner energy and that requires a
package of technology and political will
and money and at the moment that just
isn't happening
and this is the reality of where
politics and climate change dig into
each other
poland does know it will eventually give
up on coal
but getting there will be slow difficult
and expensive
adam parsons sky news poland